seit wann kann es im universum leben
geben also mal abgesehen von der frage
ob es tatsächlich noch welches neben uns
gibt oder nicht seit wann könnte leben
entstehen wann und wie ist aus dieser
heißen ursuppe nach dem urknall ein
universum geworden in dem alle bausteine
für leben vorhanden sind ein universum
in dem theoretisch auf ungefähr sechs
planeten pro tausend sternen leben
möglich ist wie wir es kennen wie sah
der anfang von all dem aus
[Musik]
das hier ist ein zweiteiler nächste
woche schauen wir uns an wie lange wir
im universum überleben können während
die erde die sonne die milchstraße alles
um uns herum zerstört wird aber legen
wir erstmal mit dem anfang los für beide
videos ist wichtig was brauchen wir
überhaupt für leben leben braucht ganz
platt formuliert erst einmal atome aus
denen es bestehen kann und in der regel
einen halbwegs festen untergrund auf dem
es im jahr leben kann leben das auf ewig
im all herumtreibt hätte es nämlich
schwer mit der fortpflanzung es klingt
jetzt erst mal gar nicht so kompliziert
ist in so einem universum aber
tatsächlich gar nicht so
selbstverständlich als nächstes braucht
leben irgendeine form der energiezufuhr
die es in nutzbare energie umwandeln
kann stoffwechsel heißt das bei uns
menschen und last but not least leben so
wie wir es kennen braucht wasser und
zwar flüssiges wasser und hier fangen
die probleme auch schon an denn wasser
hat verglichen mit der kosmischen
temperatur skala leider nur einen sehr
kleinen bereich in dem es flüssig ist
das leben braucht somit ebenfalls diesen
kleinen temperaturbereich und den zu
erreichen ist quasi intergalaktisches
lottospielen erstens müssen der stern
und zweitens der planet die richtige
größe haben drittens müssen der planet
und sein stern im richtigen abstand
zueinander sein viertens muss der planet
die richtigen strahlungs eigenschaften
haben und fünftens muss auch noch die
planetenbahnen um den stern halbwegs
gleichmäßig sein von gezeitenkräfte
fange ich jetzt mal gar nicht erst an
aber selbst wenn das alles gegeben ist
so dinge wie atome untergrund energie
wasser und temperatur hat es ja nicht
immer gegeben oder wann wurde das alles
für leben bereitgestellt wie sieht die
kosmische zeitskalen
es war einmal ein universum das begann
mit einem großen urknall bei dem es noch
nichts davon es war einfach nur
unendlich dicht und heiß und zehn
milliarden grad celsius und in dieser
hitze gab es nichts weiter als
elektronen positronen neutronen und
frames außerdem noch schwarz körper
strahlung und wenn es dunkle materie
gibt dann auch dunkle materie teilchen
mehr hält diese hitze einfach nicht aus
nur zweieinhalb minuten später sah das
ganze aber schon anders aus da hat sich
das universum bereits rapide abgekühlt
bei der genauen temperatur sind sich die
forscher nicht so einig aber sie könnte
wohl um die eine milliarde grad celsius
gelegen haben ziemlich frisch oder
zumindest im vergleich zu zwei minuten
davor bei diesen eisigen temperaturen
begann nun die größte single party des
universums innerhalb weniger minuten
fanden sich protonen in grüppchen
zusammen und bildeten wasserstoffkerne
helium kerne und ein paar deutsche ronan
beryllium und lithium kerne es war
jedoch noch zu warm für schwere elemente
wie silber oder proben nicht mal für
magnesium oder sauerstoff reichte es und
auch die single party war schnell vorbei
nach und nach wurde es zu kalt und zu
wenig dicht für die kernreaktionen die
hierfür nötig sind aber für weitere
elemente war es noch zu warm denn immer
wenn sich ein elektron an einen atomkern
bindet und sich ein vollständiges
element bildet wird es von den frei
umher fliegenden photonen innerhalb
kurzer zeit wieder getrennt und das
blieb jetzt erstmal für die nächsten
380.000 jahre so danach wurde es
irgendwann so kalt dass die photonen
nicht mehr genug energie hatten um die
elektronen fortlaufend von den
atomkernen zu trennen aus dieser zeit
stammt übrigens auch die berühmte
kosmische hintergrundstrahlung
haben maschinen ein bewusstsein das hier
ist der anfang von allem zumindest von
allem was ihr hier seht das war mein
erstes video auf diesem kanal hier der
anfang des doktor watson universums
sozusagen
und seitdem hat sich eine menge getan
ich habe den kanal hier aus meinem
wohnzimmer heraus gestartet ich habe
eine firma gegründet und ein büro
aufgebaut in dem wir jetzt mit redaktion
produktion und postproduktion die ganze
woche über an neuen videos arbeiten wir
haben ein studio eingerichtet nämlich
gerade schwer uns neue technik gekauft
und waren auftritts in ganz deutschland
unterwegs und das alles ist nur möglich
dank euch ihr seid von beginn an der
grund warum ich diese videos hier mache
und ihr seid ist die diese videos
überhaupt erst möglich machen ich glaube
es ist kein geheimnis dass wir uns als
unabhängiger kanal und als firma mit
mittlerweile elf angestellten auch
irgendwie finanzieren müssen wir machen
dass fast alle voll sein ansonsten
könnten wir videos in dieser qualität
gar nicht so regelmäßig hochladen das
klappt aktuell durch werbung durch
kooperationen und durch petri wo ihr uns
direkt unterstützen könnt page höheren
finde ich persönlich besonders cool denn
das ist die einzige finanzierung direkt
durch euch keine nervige werbung aber
stattdessen komplette unabhängigkeit
durch crowdfunding und deswegen haben
wir die letzten wochen damit verbracht
unsere gesamte patron seite komplett neu
aufzusetzen für alle die nicht wissen
wie katrin funktioniert ihr könnt uns
mit einem beliebigen beitrag monatlich
unterstützen und bekommt dafür
verschiedene benefits zum beispiel könnt
ihr bei page schülern videos wie dieses
hier früher sehen oder über die nächsten
video themen mitbestimmen ihr bekommt
auch behind the scenes videos
ungeschnittene interviews zugang zu
unseren skripten oder ihr könnt im
abspann die videos genannt werden aber
das wichtigste ist die unterstützt uns
und dabei in zukunft noch mehr
wissenschaftsjournalismus und kostenlose
videos und an dieser stelle ist es mir
auch ganz besonders wichtig nochmals zu
betonen dass unsere videos immer
kostenlos auf youtube zu sehen sein
werden ihr müsst uns nicht unterstützen
die videos könnt ihr immer gucken denn
wir sind der festen überzeugung dass
wissen jedem frei zur verfügung stehen
sollte und jeder von euch ob wir uns auf
pages unterstützt oder nicht ist teil
des doktor watson universums und in
diesem sinne zurück zu den anfängen des
anderen universums jetzt ging es aber
erst richtig los die ersten
vollständigen helium und wasserstoff
atome bildeten sich und damit haben wir
schon mal halbes wasser denn wasser
besteht aus wasserstoff und sauerstoff
h2o und die gute nachricht ist aus
dieser zeit haben wir dank der
kosmischen hintergrundstrahlung sogar
ein foto vom universum quasi sein erstes
baby foto
moment was sind denn das für komische
flecken da drauf warum ist das so
gepunktet wenn es noch fast gar nichts
gab nun es gab eben doch schon etwas
regionen mit mehr und mit weniger
photonen das hört sich jetzt erstmal
etwas unspektakulär an ist aber ziemlich
entscheidend denn jeder körper mit masse
hat auch eine gravitation das gilt
natürlich auch für atome wenn ich jetzt
ein universum mit ganz vielen davon habe
die alle die exakt gleichen abständen
zueinander haben dann wird jedes atom
gleich stark in alle richtungen gezogen
sie bleiben also unterm strich genau
dort wo sie sind und es passiert gar
nichts schon gar kein leben habe ich
aber ein paar atome auf einem haufen
ziehen diese weitere atome an und mehr
und mehr und mehr und immer mehr und was
bekomme ich dann also zumindest bin ich
dass einige hundert millionen jahre lang
so weiter mache genau sterne sterne die
anfang in ihrem inneren kernfusion zu
betreiben dadurch setzen sie zum einen
relativ gleichmäßig und verlässlich
energie frei diesen baustein für leben
gibt es also ab jetzt sogar 400
millionen jahre nach dem urknall
zum anderen schmelzen die sterne in
ihrem inneren aber auch atome zusammen
eine wahre elemente küche entsteht denn
alle basiselemente unterscheiden sich im
wesentlichen nur in der anzahl ihrer
elektronen und protonen
wasserstoff hat ein proton im kern und
einen elektron außenrum helium 2 im kern
und zwei außen rum und immer so weiter
wenn ich jetzt also mit extrem vielen
trug und energie in zwei monaten
zusammen stufe dann bekomme ich
beryllium zwei premium ergeben wiederum
sauerstoff neuen sauerstoff herzlich
willkommen im universum an dieser stelle
sei übrigens angemerkt dass es menschen
nicht ohne kohlenstoff und atem waren
sauerstoff geben kann leben an sich aber
schon das ausführlich zu erklären führt
jetzt ein bisschen zu weit aber für
leben generell brauchen wir trotzdem das
element sauerstoff nämlich für wasser
die kernfusion im inneren von sternen
ist also ein großer und wichtiger
schritt auf dem weg zum leben wir haben
also eine verlässliche energiezufuhr die
sterne wir haben die bausteine für
wasser und wir haben noch ein paar
andere basiselemente was uns jetzt noch
fehlt sind die richtige temperatur alle
schweren elemente und eine unterlage
naja wir müssen den sauerstoff ja noch
irgendwie aus dem inneren des sterns
heraus bekommen damit wir endlich wasser
basteln können die elemente küche der
sterne ist super funktioniert aber nur
bis zu helium massereiche sterne
schaffen ist bis zu 26 protonen pro atom
und das ist dann eisen danach ist dann
aber schluss sterne können also ungefähr
ein viertel aller bisher entdeckten
elemente im laufe ihres lebens
herstellen für alles darüber braucht es
eine nova oder einen super nova also
eine explosion eines sterbenden sterns
diese schleudern dann auch die
restlichen elemente die der stern im
laufe seines lebens hergestellt hat
hinaus ins universum das heißt ohne den
tod von sternen ist ein leben nicht zu
denken das universum kann auch bitter
süß sein in den elementar wolken von
gestorbenen sternen entsteht jetzt
endlich das begehrte gut in diesem
chemischen cocktail und unter einfluss
der strahlung der nächsten generation
von sternen begegnen sich nun nämlich
wasserstoff und sauerstoff atome und
verbinden sich zu unserem heißgeliebten
h2o wasser und in genau dieser umgebung
kann nun auch der letzte fehlende
baustein von leben entstehen eine art
unterlage auf der leben existieren kann
zum beispiel ein gesteinsplanet aber
auch ein mond wird es tun ein asteroid
wiederum ist eher unpraktisch wegen des
bekannten temperatur problems ähnlich
wie sterne entstehen solche
himmelskörper dadurch dass sich immer
mehr materie durch gravitation
zusammenballt bloß wie die erste
ansammlung von staubkörnern entsteht die
dann über die jahrmillionen weitere
staubkörner anzieht und sich irgendwann
bis zum planeten entwickelt das wissen
wir bis heute nicht das problem lässt
sich gut mit großen schneebällen
erklären versucht man einen herzustellen
indem man zwei kleine schneebälle
gegeneinander wird dann zerstören sie
einander beim aufprallen lässt man die
einzelnen schneeflocken einfach
beieinander liegen und wartet bis sie
sich selbst zu einem schneeball formen
erwartet man ziemlich lange die einzige
möglichkeit einen großen schneeball zu
bekommen ist einen kleinen schneeball zu
haben und ihn im schnee zu rollen so
dass langsam mehr und mehr einzelne
schneeflocken anpacken doch wer formt
den ersten kleinen schwebe auf den
ersten kleinen galaktischen staub ball
es gibt einige theorien aber die
endgültige antwort gibt den forschenden
bis heute rätsel auf wir wissen nur es
funktioniert und es funktionierte
bereits erstaunlich früh lange dachte
man dass sich gesteinsplaneten erst
mehrere milliarden jahre nach dem
urknall bilden konnten wenn genug sterne
gestorben sind doch dann entdeckte man
keppler 10c einen gesteinsplanet mit
einem alter von elf milliarden jahren
das gibt den forschern bis heute rätsel
auf aber fest steht seit 28 milliarden
jahre nach dem urknall dass er seit elf
milliarden jahren ist leben im universum
theoretisch möglich es könnte also
theoretisch leben geben dass bereits elf
milliarden jahre altes wie
wahrscheinlich das ist das erklären wir
unter anderem in diesem video hier da
geht es um eine sprache die
wissenschaftler extra für die
kommunikation mit außerirdischen leben
entwickelt haben aber wie es dann
letzten endes wirklich zu leben kommt
das ist wie beim schneeball wir wissen
dass bis heute nicht der entscheidende
funken konnte in keinem labor der erde
bisher repliziert oder verstanden werden
genauso wenig wissen wir wann das leben
im universum enden wird denn in kosmisch
betrachtet gar nicht allzu weiter ferne
wird das universum wieder ganz schön
ungemütlich wie lange können wir darin
überleben wie lange kann die menschheit
von sternensystemen zu sternensystem
hoppen während alles um uns herum
zerstört wird das beantworten wir
nächsten sonntag hier auf doktor watson
bis dahin meldet euch gerne wenn ihr den
schneeball macher des lebens gefunden
hat unterstützt uns gerne auch patron
für mehr solcher videos und bleibt
neugierig fabrik